tanti tanti anni fa gli uomini vivevano
o meglio sopravvivevano in villaggi
isolati
il giorno seguiva la notte non c'era
l'elettricità le stagioni erano quelle
che permettevano l'agricoltura
sacrificavano agli dei e auspicavano di
avere un destino felice
le tre parche decidevano i destini della
vita la prima fila va il filo la seconda
ne decideva destini a due è durata e la
terza lo recideva saccheggi schiavitù
violenze erano il modo in cui l'uomo
poteva arricchirsi sottraendo ad altri
questo era una cultura una vita
stanziale isolata sacrifici agli dèi
sfruttamento e schiavitù ma l'umanità è
cambiata è cambiata grazie alla
filosofia è cambiata perché qualcuno a
un certo punto ha concepito l'idea del
nulla assoluto da cui è venuto poi un
concetto questo concetto e lo zero
il numero zero i mercanti arabi che
viaggiarono verso l'india insieme alle
spezie portarono il lavoro il pensiero
gli scritti di brahma gusta un
matematico indiano che intorno al 650
dopo cristo introdusse lo zero nella
matematica e se noi oggi diciamo 610 per
dire non vali nulla in realtà zero vale
tantissimo questo numero sostituì con
chiamo la numerazione indo araba le
lettere dei romani e le limitazioni che
la numerazione per lettere ci dava
mohamad
al caval al cav a ritmi in latino
algoritmi è un matematico arabo che nel
ix secolo fece l'algebra e fece le prime
equazioni voi vedete 01 algoritmi oggi
il vostro telefono le possibilità i
computer vengono da lì attraverso i
mercanti arabi dall'india verso l'europa
che a volte pensa di essere l'unica
culla della civiltà lorenzo pisano detto
fibonacci nel 1202 scrisse il liber
abaci che portò in europa la
divulgazione della matematica degli aram
in questo perché aveva seguito il padre
bonaccio fibonacci sta per figlio di
bonaccio in algeria dove aveva scoperto
la matematica araba e lo zero aveva
scritto questo questa opera che poi
federico ii prese divulga ulteriormente
perché quest'opera liber abaci non
parlava solo di matematica teorica
parlava di applicazioni parlava di come
calcolare l'interesse parlava di come
fare le costruzioni e 250 anni dopo
viene detto cutrufo scrisse l'arte della
marcatura a cui io mi sono ispirato poi
per il mio libro prima citato l'arte
della startup l'arte della mercatura il
primo trattato sulla parte del commercio
perché questa arte del commercio
importante perché il commercio
al contrario di cio del saccheggio e
mutualmente benefico per chi lo fa
mercante e comporta il rischio comporta
ai viaggi
tant'è che
si ispirò facciamo per questo libro al
mercante cosimo de medici che come
sapete ebbe un certo ruolo nello
sviluppo della cultura del rinascimento
e lo stesso cutolo gli scrisse poi
quindici anni dopo il de navigazione che
il primo trattato noto europeo sulla
navigazione
questo perché nel suo libro dice che il
mercante deve conoscere le arti liberali
il quadrivio al trivio ma deve avere
anche nozioni pratiche e fra queste
nozioni pratiche anche la conoscenza
della navigazione per poter viaggiare
per poter pensare i noli per sapere da
dove vengono le merci e come
raggiungerle i costi e rischi comporre
che comporta questo quindi andare oltre
l'ignoto da questo rinascimento nel 1492
le scoperta geografica il nuovo mondo di
colombo
le scoperte artistiche e scientifiche di
leonardo la gioconda viene determinata
nel 1506 e nel 1512 e copernico che fare
una rivoluzione nella cosmografia come
vedete sono anni vicini questo
rinascimento
l'impresa e il mercante al centro di
questa rivoluzione dell'andare oltre
l'ignoto tra la scienza e la conoscenza
fra il viaggiare la volontà la volontà
che viene fuori dal destino e la volontà
di fare le cose e pensare di essere
fattori del proprio destino
calcolare il rischio e quindi poi
l'assicurazione la mutualità la
possibilità di fare le cose perché il
rischio veniva diviso la probabilità
tutto questo prima dello 0 non era
possibile e quindi oggi 2018
siamo nel paradiso terrestre sappiamo
tutto abbiamo imparato tutto e
rinascimento è qua in mezzo a noi e in
tutta la nostra vita
ma 190 milioni di europei non sono mai
andati fuori dai confini del proprio
paese
il 37 per cento in media il 52 per cento
se parliamo dell'italia solo non è mai
uscito per andare un altro paese
questa è una ricerca europea non lo so
se poi la domanda l'hanno fatta proprio
bene qualcuno in realtà andato in
vacanza a cuba a sharm el sheikh che non
ne parte dell'unione europea e quindi
andato fuori dal confine del proprio
paese ma diciamo che è una buona
approssimazione solo il 16 per cento
degli italiani a tutte le volte tutti
gli anni almeno una volta in un altro
paese europeo
quindi non abbiamo smesso di essere del
tutto isolati ben 13 milioni di italiani
ogni anno si rivolgono maghi e
fattucchiere per farsi predire il futuro
per un giro d'affari stimato di 8
miliardi
ci sono stimate dati di una ricerca su
capolarato agromafie 400mila persone
sfruttate italiani e stranieri per un
giro di 16 miliardi e del all'anno dalla
nigeria
ma non solo ma il caso della nigeria
particolare della mafia nigeriana con
riti voodoo ci sono le schiave del sesso
che ci sono perché c'è anche la domanda
perché se non ci fosse la domanda
l'offerta non ci sarebbe che vengono
sfruttate lungo le strade ei saccheggi
forse sono meno spettacolari meno
violenti di quelli del passato ma ci
sono sempre perché madoff schema ponti e
la parmalat o altri casi come quelli di
euro o di varie banche ci dicono che i
saccheggi non sono terminati quindi
ancora vita isolata credenze
sfruttamento schiavitu e violenza ma
ma non è finita qua noi siamo gli eredi
di cultura bellezza conoscenze possiamo
oggi spostarsi facilmente anche a basso
costo ma possiamo anche andare oltre i
confini della terra verso l'ignoto e
quella è un'immagine della sonda appena
atterrata su marte incredibile france
johansson ha scritto un libro effetto
medici in cui dice che la novità alle
innovazioni nascono all'intersezione fra
culture liberali e culture scientifiche
frontisti e scienziati e ha chiamato
questo effetto medici perché era nella
firenze dei medici che questo per la
prima volta nel rinascimento veramente
avvenuto questa intersezione questa
contaminazione dei saperi
quindi abbiamo davanti a noi grandi
possibilità grandi sfide questo un
quadro di rembrandt che ci pongono
davanti la possibilità di fare un nuovo
rinascimento ed è l'imprenditore che
prendendo dei rischi perché impresa e
impresa usano la stessa parola ma è come
fare l'impresa e creare un'impresa cioè
un'attività commerciale prendere rischi
chi lavora con onore prende dei rischi
ci mette la faccia non è uno sfruttatore
non è uno speculatore e quindi mi viene
da citare un grande italiano adriano
olivetti e vorrei leggervi un piccolo
parte di una sua libro dice adriano
olivetti attraverso il rigoroso rispetto
della cultura a tutti i livelli della
vita di fabbrica
noi abbiamo favorito a risplendere dei
valori spirituali la testimonianza della
bellezza il calore della tolleranza
la limpida supremazia della scienza e
adriano poi diceva sempre citando suo
padre camillo la verità risplenda solo
nei fatti non nelle parole io credo che
questo sia un grande grande esempio
ancora diciamo fruibile e mettibile in
pratica è quindi il momento di lasciare
gli ormeggi di non avere paura di andare
verso degli ignoti di affrontarle
insieme ai nuovi imprenditori e fare la
propria parte perché la grandezza sta
nel provarci
la grandezza sta nella lotta una
grandezza sta nell'iniziare qualcosa che
non finisce con noi e quindi il mio
auspicio è abbiate coraggio andate
abbracciato il mondo grazie